l'ordre du jour appelle la question de
Monsieur Michel doublet
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
porte sur l'avenir de l'armée de l'air
en Charente-Maritime ainsi que sur
l'évolution des effectifs et des
missions à la suite de l'apparition du
Livre blanc sur la défense et la
sécurité nationale et des propositions
de réduction des effectifs et de
réorganisation les acteurs concernés ont
fait part de leur inquiétude quand on
d'orientation future et aux éventuelles
impacts sur le tissu économique et
social du territoire la loi de
programmation militaire pour
2014-2019 a été publié le 19 décembre
ainsi pour les cinq premières années
prochaines années le ministère de
défense subira à 23500 suppression de
poste et pâtira d'un manque
d'investissement qui fera le moins de
1,5% du PIB en 2019 avec des risques en
termes de décrochage capacitaires et
stratégique de la France je souhaiterais
orienter ma question sur l'évolution des
effectifs et des missions de la base
aérienne 721 siège de l'école de
formation des sous-officiers de l'armée
de l'air qui est fils à cette année
le 3 octobre dernier vous avez précisé
les sites faisant l'objet de
restructuration pour l'armée de terre et
de l'Armée de l'Air ces annonces sont
toujours vécues difficilement par les
élus et l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques quant aux mesures
d'accompagnement elles sont
indispensables
la Charente-Maritime connaît bien les
difficultés pour avoir su les affronter
et de nombreux à de nombreux reprises si
notre département n'est pas concerné par
les annonces de restructuration pour
2013 la visibilité à long terme n'est
toujours pas de mise comme vous l'avez
indiqué les décisions relatives à la
prochaine tranche de restructuration
feront communiquer courant en 2014
à l'aube des élections municipales qui
ont lieu en mars prochain la présence de
l'armée sur un territoire et un impact
économique et social très important et
influe sur les projets d'investissement
et de fonctionnement d'une commune ou
d'une collectivité
j'imagine bien qu'en ce début d'année
vous ne pourrez pas m'apporter
d'éléments tangible sur l'avenir des
bases de mon département mais je
souhaiterais toutefois pouvoir
accueillir aux observations en la
matière et faire un point d'étape sur le
calendrier à venir monsieur mini je vous
remercie pour votre réponse
merci Monsieur doublet monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur Michel
doubleting
ce matin ma demandé de répondre en son
nom à la question que vous venez de
poser et à s'excuser de sa non présente
c'est l'école les écoles des
sous-officiers militaires durant de
l'Armée de l'Air implantait un
Charente-Maritime assure la formation
militaire initiale et complémentaire des
sous-officiers militaires durant ainsi
que la formation professionnelle du
personnel de certaines de ses
spécialistes dont les techniciens
aéronautiques le milieu aéronautique
représente un secteur dans lequel
évolutions technologiques sont très
rapides et les systèmes d'armes mis en
oeuvre chaque jour plus complexe par
ailleurs les armées n'échappent pas à
l'évolution et renforcement continu
d'énormes et dérèglements navigabilité
environnement cela pose pour l'armée de
l'air une exigence croissante en matière
de compétences des ressources humaines
parallèlement la publication du Livre
blanc de la défense de la sécurité
nationale 2013 et l'adoption de la loi
de militaire 2014-2019 maintiennent une
dynamique de transformation des armées
vers un modèle plus resserré les
fermetures de sites des solutions sont
et seront limitées à ce qui est
nécessaire pour atteindre le modèle
d'armée 2025 défini par le livre blanc
en 2014 les unités de l'Armée de l'Air
implantaient un Charente-Maritime
contribueront à l'effort de déflation
des effectifs du ministère de la Défense
d'environ 80 postes considérant la
taille actuelle de la base aérienne de
Saintes et sa proximité géographique
avec celle de Rochefort il a été décidé
d'alléger sa structure de commandement
en la rattachant à la base aérienne de
Rochefort pour le soutien spécifique et
la gestion du personnel en conséquence
la base aérienne de Saintes deviendra un
élément r rattaché à l'été 2014 ceux qui
se traduira par une déflation d'une
quarantaine de postes la base aérienne
de Rochefort fera quant à elle l'objet
de mesures d'optimisation de ces
services qui se traduiront également par
une diminution de ses négatif de lors
d'une quarantaine de postes plus
généralement en matière de
restructuration territoriale la loi de
programmation militaire récemment
adoptée par le Parlement explicite les
critères de base qui orienteront les
décisions du gouvernement en ce domaine
dans les années à venir ainsi les
effectifs proprement opérationnels liées
au contrat assigné aux forces par le
chef de l'État ne représenteront pas
plus d'un tiers des déflation pour leur
grande majorité les diminutions
d'effectifs reposeront donc sur un
effort important touchant
l'administration au sens large et
l'environnement des forces le ministre
de la Défense attachera également dans
ces décisions un grand prix à la
préservation d'une articulation
cohérente entre les armées et les
territoires à la prise en compte
d'aménagement économique de ceci et au
respect du lien armé nation ceci
signifie monsieur sédentes monsieur le
sénateur que dans le cadre de ces
restructurations le gouvernement ne
procédera de façon ni arithmétique ni
automatique la mise en oeuvre concret de
ces principes imposent de prendre le
temps de l'analyse fonctionnelle afin
d'éviter des erreurs majeures ou des
retours en arrière préjudiciaires de la
crédibilité et à la prévisibilité de
notre politique je vous remercie merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur doublet
j'ai bien entendu votre réponse et je
vous en remercie vous comprenez
l'inquiétude qu'on les élus proches donc
de cette base parce que nous sommes dans
un département un peu sinistré au point
de vue de l'emploi et là-bas représente
un potentiel important économique et
social comme tout à l'heure donc nous
veillerons et je pense qu'ensemble on
veillera à ce que cette base demeure
toujours à Rochefort et ne soit pas
démembrée ou diminué en effectif merci
Monsieur doublet